j'ouvre tout de suite le second débat de
ce sens public je vous propose un gros
plan sur l'été des festivals les plus
réputés sont frappés de plein fouet par
l'inflation notamment les cachets
délirants de certaines stars
internationales et les plus modestes ont
eux aussi du mal à boucler leur budget
résultats des rendez-vous culturels qui
passent leur tour d'autres qui sont
contraints d'augmenter le prix des
billets comme au festival pop rock de
beaux regards on est dans le Calvados
reportage sur cette équation de plus en
plus difficile à résoudre avec Flora
sauvage avec 150 jours l'édition 2023 du
festival de Beauregard près de Caen à
pulvériser tous ces records Indochine
Louise Attaque PLK ou tiacola
l'engouement est-elle que tous les
billets ont été vendus dès le mois de
février du jamais vu mais après la crise
sanitaire l'inflation menace les
festivals de musique cachait des
artistes location de matériel il subisse
de plein fouet la hausse des coûts liée
à l'organisation les enjeux sont très
importants de plus en plus difficiles à
tenir on est sur des événements qui
avancent amortissaient autour des 80% de
taux de remplissage c'est-à-dire qu'il
fallait qu'on remplisse 80% de notre
jauge pour arriver à zéro en termes de
de bilan financiers et désormais là bon
regarde on est entre 92 et 94 % de taux
de remplissage pour avoir notre
amortissement ce qui est juste énorme et
c'est un défi monstrueux pour répondre à
ce défi bon nombre de festivals ont
décidé d'augmenter le prix des billets
au grand dames des festivaliers à
Beauregard 65% des recettes se font sur
la billetterie c'est normal que ça
augmente parce que c'est les artistes
c'est sur là où ils sont du cachets
parce que maintenant la vente de CD
c'est plus rien du tout donc c'est que
sur les concerts après c'est comme tout
fait tout augmente donc c'est forcément
pénible pour tout le monde quoi tous les
jours on vient avec des sandwichs c'est
comme ça et on peut peut-être un soir on
se fait plaisir on achète des trucs sur
place quoi implanter au cœur du Calvados
le festival de Beauregard met en avant
les retombées économiques qui génèrent
c'est un budget de 10 millions d'euros
sur ces 10 millions d'euros on a déjà
plus de 3 millions d'euros qui sont
investis dans des entreprises régionales
donc les retombées économiques oui elles
sont elles sont puissantes sur nos
événements d'autant plus que la plupart
des événements sont très peu financés
ont très peu de financement public il
faut le savoir bon regarde c'est moins
d'1 % de subventions publiques pour le
maire d'Hérouville-Saint-Clair le
festival de Beauregard apporte beaucoup
à sa commune ça donne véritablement une
belle image surtout quand on est
effectivement Aéroville c'est 23000
habitants c'est la deuxième ville du
Calvados et puis avec ses qualités ses
défauts vous voyez on a occupé on est
dans l'actualité avec ce qui s'est passé
il y a maintenant quelques jours avec
les nuits d'émeutes c'est comment
revaloriser comme quoi il y a des
richesses et des potentiels et donc un
peu de allez un peu de après ces
amertume après ces moments de doutes
c'est dire c'est la culture la musique
rassemble
[Musique]
elles sont heureuses de retrouver
l'ambiance de l'avancée
[Musique]
après pomme Interpol ou encore PLK Sting
à clôturer le festival de Beauregard
pour le plus grand bonheur des
festivaliers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous commencez avec vous monsieur le
gars parce que
les festivals c'est un amalgame c'est
hyper contrasté il y a ceux qui sont
publics ceux qui sont privés ceux qui
sont historiques ceux qui sont tout
jeunes ceux qui sont pas des toutes
petites villes enfin bref mais est-ce
que on peut craindre un été sinistré ou
pas non non je crois qu'il y a 6000
festivals en France on échappant du
monde des festivals on adore ça les
Français adorent pleurer ils adorent
rire aussi j'ai l'impression et y aller
et je crois qu'il s'est créé des
festivals en 2023 je crois que rien que
pour la région
Occitanie il y a une quantaine de
festivals en plus donc je veux dire il y
a toujours des envies etc de le faire je
crois qu'il faudrait faire chaque fois
un bilan aussi parce qu'il y en a qui se
créent il y en a qui renoncent mais
voilà non non il y aura pas il y a non
non il y a absolument pas de de
sinistrose c'est quand même encore un
des formats qui remplit le mieux parce
que c'est un format où les gens n'ont
pas peur d'aller contrairement à
d'autres formes artistiques je pense
mine de rien pousser la pose la porte
d'un centre d'art ou pousser apporte
d'un opéra pour des gens ça bloque mais
allez voir un concert dans un dans un
cadre un peu bucolique sympathique voilà
on y va beaucoup facilement pendant le
festival d'orange je sais pas Antoine
Pecker sera mieux que moi j'ai
l'impression que attire beaucoup de
festivaliers qui vont voir de leur
lyrics ou du classique il n'y avait
jamais il n'irait jamais le reste de
l'année donc voilà il y a tous ces
formats là qui font et donc non personne
alors ce qui est vrai c'est que le taux
de rentabilité de certains festivals est
tellement difficile c'est-à-dire ça joue
à rien ça joue à rien entre équilibré
parle beaucoup d'argent ou en gagner à
peine et c'est sous la difficulté ça
vaut beaucoup pour les festivals en
effet non subventionnés et beaucoup pour
les festivals de musique et de notamment
de musique rock de musique populaire
c'est ce qu'on voyait effectivement dans
notre dans notre reportage
antoecker c'est le tout moi je suis
frappé par ce chiffre quand on a un taux
de pour atteindre la rentabilité faut
être à 95% de de remplissage c'est pas
si simple de l'atteindre saison après
saison quoi donc la question que la
question centrale de
votre débat est-ce que ce modèle
économique est menacé vous répondez quoi
à cette question effectivement le modèle
économique il est périlleux parce que on
voit évidemment d'un côté en termes de
dépenses une hausse des dépenses avec
les questions de l'énergie notamment et
d'autres et puis de l'autre côté cette
question des recettes avec l'inquiétude
sur pouvoir d'achat on peut pas
augmenter le prix des places à l'infini
donc il y a effectivement pour certains
le seuil de rentabilité c'est même
au-delà de 100% de taux de fréquentation
donc on est une obligation de résultat
absolument absolument dingue donc
effectivement aujourd'hui il y a des
vraies questions qui se posent mais il
n'empêche que le secteur là pour y poser
des questions parce qu'on a vu après
cette crise sanitaire des interrogations
sur le retour du public et notamment
dans le cadre des saisons
traditionnelles de salle de spectacle
parfois un peu compliqué mais pour les
festivals ce n'est pas le cas il y a
quelques jours j'étais à Jazz à Vienne
c'est simple c'est l'édition historique
le plus grand score de fréquentation
cette année pour jazz avis alors
j'entends sur lui donc ça veut dire que
autant les salles de spectacle sur sur
l'année
ont du mal à remplir autant les festival
font venir le public parce que d'octobre
ajouin ils doivent repenser leur modèle
notamment le modèle des abonnements par
exemple aujourd'hui ne fonctionne plus
parce que les gens fonctionnent de plus
en plus au jour le jour et cette logique
d'événements et ben c'est celle des
festivals par définition et en plus
effectivement au festival ça ajoute les
études le montrent à la motivation du
public c'est notamment outre les
artistes le lieu l'ambiance ce lien là
au public et je crois qu'après la crise
sanitaire les gens ont envie aussi de
retrouver ce lien Sylvie Robert on va
parler du Festival d'Avignon vous vous
en revenez vous étiez il y a voilà
quelques quelques jours quelques heures
les autres festivals un mot des autres
festivals est-ce que effectivement vous
vous avez des retours des territoires de
d'une fréquentation qui se maintient ou
qui augmente cet été oui alors on est on
est quand même à plus de 7000 festivals
aujourd'hui donc c'est vraiment oui
vraiment et vous avez raison de dire il
y en a qui disparaissent il y en a qui
se créent c'est vraiment mais ça reste
quand même on va dire une sorte de
marque de fabrique de notre pays on aime
et c'est beaucoup la saison estivale
même si de plus en plus de festivals
mais on y reviendra pour les raisons que
on vient dénoncer comment ça se dire que
ce serait pas mal dans la dans l'année
de donner des rendez-vous au public mais
globalement voilà c'est quand même c'est
quand même un moment attendu et je pense
que ça va être une année assez
exceptionnelle parce que l'année
dernière il y avait déjà encore un peu
la baisse les pratiques culturelles des
Français étaient pas encore complètement
revenus comme avant le covid Manon le
voit quand même dans les salles même si
il y a entre eux encore entre 20 et 30%
de baisse de fréquentation mais c'est
pas partout
mais globalement sur les festivals je
pense qu'on va avoir une belle saison
expira et les chiffres sont au
rendez-vous alors on va faire un point
tout de suite avec Pierre Jean de Renaud
77e Festival d'Avignon c'est jusqu'au 25
juillet il y a quoi une petite semaine
on va dire de de festivals quels sont
les voyants sont au vert quel est votre
premier bilan
un bilan très positif pour cette
ouverture on en est à 7 jours maintenant
de festival pour 77e édition et on se
satisfait bien sûr de la fréquentation
qui est excellente dans l'ensemble des
dieux du Festival d'Avignon et puis plus
généralement cette année par exemple on
avait ouvert la billetterie dès le mois
d'avril qui était quand même un
changement pour le festival et très vite
on a vu une réponse assez positive de la
part du public ce qui nous permet aussi
aujourd'hui avec une jauge qui a par
ailleurs augmenté pour cette édition de
pouvoir proposer encore des places à la
vente pour la plupart des spectacles qui
se déroulent actuellement en plus tous
les voyants sont ouverts pour pour ce
démarrage et on a une vraie ferveur du
public un public certes de personnes qui
peuvent être habituées à venir au
festival parfois depuis plusieurs
décennies mais aussi un grand
renouvellement des publics avec en
moyenne 15% du public qui vient pour la
première fois au festival chaque année
et là vous nous parlez du festival pour
ceux qui ne connaissent pas du festival
in le festival officiel ou de d'Avignon
dans son ensemble in et le Off
du Festival d'Avignon qui communément
par les autres acteurs de l'écosystème
est appelé le festivaline effectivement
il y a un ensemble de festivals qui ont
lieu à Avignon et notamment bien sûr le
Havre qui rassemble 130 lieux et 1500
compagnies je ne suis pas habilités
évidemment c'était pour que ce soit bien
clair dans l'esprit de nos
téléspectateurs évidemment on va
beaucoup parler de l'inflation dans ce
débat et je vous propose un premier
élément une question posée par c'était
au Sénat c'était au mois de mai dernier
posé par la sénatrice LR des Ardennes L2
Joseph écoutez en raison d'une d'une
succession de problèmes liés au contexte
mais pas que les spectacles doivent
réduire leur taille pour éviter une une
des routes financières ainsi la récente
poussée inflationniste avec en
particulier l'augmentation des prix de
l'énergie qui ont été multipliés par 3
voir par 4 à conduit à des situations
compliquées les saisons ont été
raccourcis et on déplore beaucoup
le Syndicat national des scènes
publiques a annoncé plus de 100 000
spectateurs perdus pour cette année où
en est-on réellement alors Sylvie Robert
je reviens sur ce chiffre 100000
spectateurs perdus pour certains pour
cette année je sais pas s'il est encore
vrai un mois et demi après mais ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire des festivals qui
décident de passer leur tour en quelque
sorte cette saison parce que c'est trop
compliqué ça explique comment la ce que
ce que disait ma collègue c'était elle
parlait beaucoup des salles et des
programmations c'est à dire que le
festivals c'est un peu différent
c'est-à-dire qu'on était dans la
effectivement avec le
coup
énergétique etc on n'a pas écouté tout
le Son pardon mais elle parlait des
festivals là on a l'impression qu'elle
parle que des salles de spectacle mais
des salles de spectacle parce que c'est
un vrai sujet il y a eu des moins de
spectacles parfois ou des programmations
qui ont effectivement vu leur spectacle
baissé sur les festivals aujourd'hui le
dernier chiffre que j'ai eu puisque
effectivement je reviens d'Avignon c'est
25% supplémentaires de coûts
supplémentaires
25%. alors France festival donc c'est
c'est à mesurer ça et et dit très
clairement ils feront le bilan après
mais que quand même beaucoup sur les
festivals qui ne sont pas subventionnés
on a parlé des jauges tout à l'heure il
y aura quand même beaucoup de déficits
et ils annoncent déjà des épicés donc
c'est un c'est un sujet important mais
je ne suis pas certaine que ils aient
pour autant réduit leur format vous
voyez ce qui est normal ils ont parié
sur un retour du public et je pense
qu'ils ont eu raison juste une mention
c'est quand même un modèle c'est comme
les startups finalement c'est un modèle
qui s'adapte très bien et qui correspond
très bien aux attentes d'aujourd'hui
c'est un modèle qui existe depuis
longtemps mais qui était finalement
moderne et qui reste moderne dans sa
façon d'attirer de
jaillir comme ça dans une un format
différent ou quoi et ça donne
l'impression que le modèle de subvention
ou de financement n'est pas forcément
on finance pas une entreprise vieillotte
un peu traditionnelle comme on finance
une start-up et on a l'impression que là
il faudrait peut-être tâtonner pour les
aider pour faire face à des événements
comme ça conjoncturels de l'inflation
alors que globalement ou peut-être les
aider à avoir des pratiques communes
parce qu'on sait que ça repose beaucoup
sur la société civile aussi beaucoup de
bénévoles beaucoup de non en argent
finalement beaucoup de temps passé
peut-être les aider d'une manière
différente parce qu'on voit que ce
modèle il peut perdurer même s'il est
sale et on le voit très bien les salles
de cinéma de théâtre ou quoi sont un
petit peu désertés
effectivement la question peut se poser
dans un contexte inflationniste quelques
quelques chiffres pour rebondir sur ce
que vous nous disiez entre 2019 et 2022
on avait déjà une augmentation des
charges et évaluée à près de 20% plus
19%, et puis alors ça continue avec une
inflation des cachets on parle des
cachets des artistes un plus stress pour
cent en moyenne et ça peut aller
beaucoup plus haut pour les têtes
d'affiches internationales augmentation
des frais techniques de l'énergie des
coûts de sécurité des assurances aussi
on a trouvé ce chiffre avec des
assurances pour augmenter de plus de de
20% plus 21 pour 100 je voudrais quand
même qu'on prenne un peu de temps sur
les cachets des stars internationales
Michel alors ça concerne pas tous les
festivals évidemment je sais pas
concerné
pas 3 millions comme Metallica on a on
avait ça dans les tout à l'heure
c'est difficile de savoir c'est
difficile alors non il y a eu quand même
plusieurs entretiens notamment avec le
patron du Hellfest et qui expliquait
bien comment
je sais pas moi le nombre de de stars de
la musique ça joue sur la musique c'est
très on est bien d'accord et sur les on
parle on parle de quelques festivals les
plus gros festivals
je pense qu'on est très loin de tout ça
mais c'est dit de voir d'ailleurs le
public et voir Saint-Germain c'est des
concerts qui font 20 30 50 000 personnes
avaient été avec des et en fait ils
équilibrent en général quand vous avez
des énormes cachés c'est que vous avez
un festival mais il y a une inflation
mais il y a une inflation sur une
inflation sur les cacher vous une
inflation sur les sur les tickets de
vente quoi donc en gros et moi je pense
que il faudra vraiment attendre la fin
vraiment fin août début septembre
mi-septembre octobre pour voir vraiment
s'il y aura la casse ou pas etc alors en
effet donc par le patron du Hellfest
disait que quand il avait une personne
de 30 ans enfin une rockstar qui était
payée en gros un million d'euros la
soirée maintenant ils sont 5 ou 6 quand
c'était à 200000 c'est à 400 000 quand
c'est à 400 c'est 600 donc en fait oui
il y a une montée générale qui concerne
d'ailleurs beaucoup plus les plus hauts
cachés que les plus bas les plus bas
donc montent pas voilà et et voilà donc
après vous avez des festivals qui ont
supprimé certains têtes d'affiches pour
pouvoir tenir dans leur économie
certains ont réduit la voilure au niveau
justement de ces deux ces personnages je
crois pas le festival les organes de
Belfort cette année n'a pas pris
certaines stars qu'ils auraient pris
peut-être la précédente les Vieilles
Charrues qui vont avoir lieu bientôt je
crois les pompiers ont gardé quelques
énormes têtes d'affiches donc voilà
attendons de voir comment ça comment
vous l'expliquez cette cette inflation
est-ce qu'il y a de nouveaux pays
concurrents entre guillemets
terribles et puis en plus
et donc les artistes effectivement il y
a il y a un enjeu de rentabilité
beaucoup plus important sur les
festivals et sur les concerts et bien
compris ça mais est-ce qu'il y a une
nouvelle concurrence internationale une
certaine façon mais je pense surtout
qu'il y a une autre concurrence Thomas
c'est la crise climatique la crise
environnementale elle l'oblige elle
impose les festivals à repenser leur
modèle parce qu'aujourd'hui regardez les
festivals qui se déroulent très
malotairement dans le sud de la France
avec des températures caniculaires un
peu plus cher une grande partie des
spectacles en plein air c'est le cas à
Avignon et c'est le cas ailleurs il faut
vraiment repenser repenser la taille des
juges je pense qu'on peut plus faire ces
festivals débordants même parfois
annexant des surfaces agricoles
balançant énormément d'eau sur les
spectateurs au même moment où les
agriculteurs on demande de ne pas
utiliser la même eau donc je pense qu'il
y a vraiment à repenser ça et notamment
est-ce que le modèle des tournées des
grands groupes
la question économique la question des
exclusivités parce que le vrai scandale
notamment du secteur c'est celui des
exclusivités dire qu'un artiste peut se
produire dans un endroit mais pas dans
un périmètre géographique proche alors
évidemment ça d'un point de vue
environnemental c'est une catastrophe ça
participe à cette question des cachets
cette osé cachés je pense vraiment qu'il
y a un circuit plus vertueux à repenser
et notamment c'est le signe tank le
chiffre projet que celui de Jean-Marc
Jean-Côme ici qui a fait toute une étude
sur la culture et notamment les
festivals il faut penser notamment que
l'un des facteurs majeurs c'est les
déplacements du public et je pense que
là aussi on peut repenser les
déplacements des festivaliers justement
je parlais de Jazz à Vienne et ben il y
a des trains qui mettent en place
spécialement après le public après le
spectacle il reprend le train pour aller
à Lyon c'est pas mal comme idée parce
que quand on fait quand on fait le bilan
environnemental d'un festival d'un
événement sportif c'est pareil c'est le
déplacement du public
j'adore ils sont tous verts maintenant
les festivals ils vont ils vous font des
vous savez quand vous allez un festival
il vous en donne une liste de 50 actions
et en plus
je suis allé à will of green par exemple
et pour aller écouter Orelsan voir ce
que c'était Orelsan passionnant et et
mais c'est fantastique ils font ils font
en plein d'efforts enfin quand même
meilleure façon pour être vers cette
affaire de festival ce genre de choses
oui mais qu'est-ce qu'on arrête les
grandes tournées internationales ou les
festivals pour des pour des raisons
écologiques mais c'est pas exactement
l'angle de notre de notre
débat mais c'est très bien
sur le contrat d'exclusivité vraiment
alors c'est c'est quoi exactement
pourquoi c'est ça pose une question
importante pour vous à partir du moment
où on organise une tournée ce qui est
intéressant c'est de pouvoir aller dans
différents lieux qui sont pas si loin
que ça quand vous avez un contrat
d'exclusivité sur un artiste sur un
festival il va prendre l'avion avec
toute son toute son équipe il va aller
dans un festival je sais pas mais
épiderminé l'exclusivité une date dans
un pays et ensuite il va devoir faire
des milliers de kilomètres ce sont des
festivals privés non on est d'accord il
y a pas de subventions d'accord
on peut avoir des pratiques un peu
vertueuses on peut aussi quand même
aller voir les principes vertueuses et
festivals quand il y a la
compétitions sont en train d'essayer de
venir avec les vertus donc pourquoi la
culture mais je suis pas d'accord je
pense que par exemple
l'impact écologique des festivals
charrues que je connais bien c'est dans
ma région je pense aussi aux festival
Avignon parce que il y a énormément des
enjeux et Thiago Rodrigues vraiment là à
cœur de travailler aussi sur cette
dimension là je pense qu'il y a des
pratiques vertueuses il y a des
dispositions à prendre et il a déjà
beaucoup de festival il commence à
mettre en hauteur je veux dire c'est pas
sûr que ça va aller je reprends la main
pardon mais là je vois qu'on revienne
aux dimensions business et notamment
cette question des subventions parce que
elle elle est liée à la question des
cachets et notamment des des artistes
internationaux alors justement j'ouvre
le débat moi on a retrouvé alors ça date
de 2017 c'est le magazine Capital qui
nous donnait une liste de de festivals
ce que coûte les grands festivals de
musique de l'été au contribuable et on a
Printemps de Bourges soliday
Francofolies avec plus d'un million
d'euros facile de voilà ce que coûte le
ces festivals au contribuable est-ce que
je sais pas si on en est toujours là 6
ans après voilà je suis transparent
c'est de 2017 on n'a pas forcément
trouvé le mieux est-ce que Sylvie Robert
il y a aujourd'hui de grands festivals
qui touchent beaucoup d'argent public et
qui verse de gros cachets à des à des
artistes internationaux et est-ce que
c'est logique pour vous non je ne pense
pas que ça soit le cas et tant mieux
parce que je pense que alors de quoi
parle-t-on si on parle du Festival
d'Avignon c'est un festival subventionné
par l'État et les collectivités
territoriales bien sûr ils ont des
financements privés mais globalement
c'est un festival subventionné si on
parle les Vieilles Charrues faisons
c'est un festival entièrement privé avec
des grandes têtes d'affiches et
heureusement
il peut y avoir
un accompagnement public sur par exemple
la scène émergentes mais mais
extrêmement c'est rien par rapport à
l'ensemble du du budget du festival donc
je pense qu'il faut et il y a des
festivals qui sont dans une mixité de
financement vous en avez cité où il y a
un certain nombre de collectivités voire
même de l'État encore que vous savez il
est il est sur la question des festivals
il y en a très peu qui sont aujourd'hui
été par l'État
il est pas bon
festival de 10 millions d'euros qui a
été dégagée sur la dernière loi de
finance que j'espère
qui va être si terrible c'est le fond
festival de 10 millions d'euros qui
j'espère va être va être pérennisé sur
la la loi de finance 2024 23 mais 24
pardon mais c'est beaucoup les
collectivités et les spécial que vous
avez cités c'est beaucoup les
collectivités territoriales sur des
actions voilà qui mènent
l'accompagnement d'artistes sur régional
d'un festival on va aussi parler de ça
mais le temps file je voudrais redonner
la parole une première fois à
Pierre-Jean Dronneau peut-être pour que
vous nous disiez on va faire le constat
de effectivement ce que ce qu'un
festival aussi prestigieux que cavignon
touche de l'État ou des collectivités
locales ça représente quelle part de
votre budget
alors le Festival d'Avignon a un budget
aux alentours de 17 millions d'euros et
il est composé à 55% de ressources
publiques et donc de subventions et 45%
de recettes propres sur ces ressources
publiques qui représentent environ 8
millions d'euros par an la moitié est
prise en charge par l'État et le reste
est réparti au niveau des différentes
collectivités territoriales de la région
jusqu'à la ville
ce qu'on a fait comme études d'impact
sur les retombées directes économiques
sur le territoire donc je le rappelle
avec au départ 8 millions d'euros
répartis sur cinq collectivités
publiques qui nous subventionnent c'est
un retour direct de 52 millions d'euros
de retombées je pense donc
la question structurante du Festival
d'Avignon en termes de batteurs
d'emplois aussi de filières
[Musique]
parti pour tous les métiers de la
restauration dans le bassin vauclusien
et puis aux alentours
extrêmement importante et plus à
démontrer et si c'était besoin de le
faire l'année d'annulation en 2020 pour
cause de covid et impact économique
extrêmement négatif qu'elle a eu sur
voilà surtout le batteur d'emploi et sur
de nombreuses filières continuent de le
prouver alors ça je suis désolé je
m'excuse auprès de téléspectateurs le
son est pas et pas parfait donc j'espère
qu'on va pouvoir améliorer ça d'ici à la
fin du du débat Émilie on va on va on va
faire un focus sur à la fois les aides
de l'État et puis ensuite les aides
territoriales d'abord l'état qui
soutient les festivals à quelle hauteur
et comment alors il participe à leur
développement même si son soutien bien
plus modeste que celui des collectivités
on parle de 5 millions d'euros pour
l'État en 2021 contre 350 millions 50
millions
oui 50 millions et 300 millions en 2021
pour les collectivités ça c'est le
rapport de la Cour des comptes de 2023
qui le dit le ministère de la Culture
donc subventionne directement près de
600 festivals on l'a dit tout à l'heure
ils sont plus de 7000 sur tout le
territoire 50 millions en 2021 46,7
millions en 2022 et à peu près la même
somme en 2023 ça va faire moins avec
l'inflation évidemment et vous le dites
c'est peu par rapport aux collectivités
et puis il faut le dire c'est quand même
absorber à 25 % par 2 gros festivals on
la cité le Festival d'Avignon et puis il
y a aussi le festival lyrique
d'Aix-en-Provence qui a lieu en ce
moment alors c'est pas forcément un
problème que ces deux gros événements
absorbent tout ça parce que comme on l'a
dit ça draine beaucoup de monde de
touristes à des retomber économiques
pour être territoires mais il a dit déjà
ce que ça donnait pour le Festival
d'Avignon ce qui est plus embêtant
est-ce que soulève la Cour des comptes
c'est que l'un des objectifs prioritaire
du ministère de la Culture la
démocratisation culturelle elle n'est
pas forcément de mise pour ses festivals
alors si on y regarde un petit peu de
plus près pour Avignon par exemple
j'espère que Pierre-Jean Reno m'en
voudra pas mais c'est ce que la Cour des
comptes dit finalement quand on voit le
profil sociologique du public il est
resté très stable entre 2013 et 2022 je
vous le donne c'est des catégories
sociales élevées et fortement diplômés
on parle d'une grande majorité en 70 %
de Bac + 3 près de 40 % qui sont
au-dessus de Bac + Kate des ouvriers
sont sous représentés ils comptent pour
moi de 3% des festivaliers les employés
c'est 7% côté âge on est autour de 48
ans et la part des moins de 35 ans
diminuant de moitié entre 2014 et 2021
elle passe de 32% à 16% celle des plus
de 65 ans elle augmente jusqu'à 30% en
2021 alors ces données elles sont jugées
préoccupantes par la Cour des comptes
surtout quand on sait que ce festival et
on l'a dit tout à l'heure mais une
politique vous inquiétez pas une
politique volontariste pour rajeunir et
diversifier son public on a entendu tout
à l'heure aussi les 15% de de première
fois de festivaliers qui sont là pour la
première fois euh il y a des tarifs
privilégiés pour les moins de 25 allez
la conclusion de la Cour des comptes
assez dur aucune diversification sociale
des publics n'est à l'oeuvre en gros la
Cour des comptes dit la démocratisation
culturelle est en panne la ministre de
la Culture a cherché à minimiser ses
critiques dans le rapport en mettant en
avant la nouvelle charte des principes
d'engagement de l'État au fait en faveur
des festivals ça a été élaboré en 2021
dans le cadre des États généraux des
festivals et définit notamment toutes
les conditions d'éligibilité des
festivals au soutien de l'État donc on
peut se dire que ça peut être un petit
peu corset et puis la ministre a aussi
mis en avant le Pass Culture qui est
disponible et qui a permis l'achat de
200000 places de festivals c'est surtout
pour la musique bon c'est un tout petit
début on va dire mais c'est un début de
démocratisation culturelle allez Antoine
Pecker d'abord sur avant de retrouver
Pierre Jean Dronneau sur sur la
ventilation de ces subventions publiques
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez mais en
fait c'est vraiment intéressant parce
que c'est origine Bachelot qui avait dit
faux une politique en faveur des
festivals et ça accouche d'un fond de
des millions d'euros 10 millions d'euros
c'est le montant de subvention publique
du seul festival d'Aix-en-Provence donc
il y a 10 millions d'euros pour tous les
festivals de France et 10 millions de
subventions publiques pour le seul
festival d'Aix-en-Provence or le
Festival d'Aix-en-Provence aujourd'hui
le prix déplace en première catégorie
c'est 300 euros est-ce que l'État est là
pour subventionner à telle hauteur un
festival qui est sa réponse à cette
question de diversification du public du
public mais des places à 300 euros en
première catégorie et là il y a vraiment
une vraie question qui se pose parce que
la diversification on l'a ailleurs dans
tous ses festivals notamment en milieu
rural qui aujourd'hui ne sont aidés que
par les collectivités territoriales
premier financeur par ailleurs de la
culture il faut toujours le rappeler
mais l'État doit puisque jamais ne pas
se limiter dans son aide à seulement
quelques gros opérateurs pour qui sont
dans une démarche parfois vraiment
délitisme et voilà c'est une évidence
mais on a l'impression que ce discours
là il est dit il est redit maintenant
arrimable Malak la mise de la culture de
prendre ce dossier à breakor parce que
sinon les collectivités territor
aujourd'hui face à la situation
économique qu'elle traverse il pourrait
y avoir de la casse parce qu'il faut
bien préciser que autant les festivals
de musique actuelle effectivement
possédés par des grands groupes comme
Live Nation ou autre sont dans un
système privé autant notamment pour la
musique classique par exemple ou pour
d'autres arts ça dépend de ces
subventions publiques sans ces
subventions ces festivals ne peuvent pas
vivre Pierre-Jean de Renaud donc je
rappelle ce que ce que nous disait enfin
la Cour des comptes à 25% du total des
subventions absorbées par deux gros
festivals Avignon et Aix-en-Provence
est-ce que vous voilà comment vous
justifiez vous finalement de votre point
de vue
je vais plutôt répondre sur la question
de la démocratisation culturelle et la
diversification des publics en disant
deux choses d'abord effectivement c'est
une étude de la Cour des comptes qui
porte sur une période pour laquelle nous
étions pas encore en mandat avec Tiago
Rodriguez nous nous sommes arrivés cette
année c'est notre première édition nous
sommes là pour 4 ans et une des
premières mesures fortes qui a été prise
ça a été de mettre en avant notre
initiative première fois qui travaille à
organiser de la venue pour la première
fois au festival d'Avignon dès cette
édition et que tu es en cours en ce
moment même de 5000 jeunes qui
assisteront qui sont âgés entre 13 et 19
ans et qui est assez pour la première
fois au festival d'Avignon qui
bénéficiait d'un parcours de spectateurs
accompagné par des médiatrices des
médiateurs qui ont été spécifiquement
recrutés pour accompagner les premières
fois et ça c'est un engagement très fort
qu'on a pris dès cette année qui a été
rendu possible aussi par ce que nous
avons augmenté d'une façon assez
importante la jauge globale de l'édition
et donc ça c'est un vrai travail qu'on
fait auprès des jeunes et qu'on va
suivre évidemment et renouveler et
intensifier des prochaines éditions pour
pouvoir répondre à cette question du
renouvellement et surtout la
diversification des publics puisque par
ailleurs tout à l'heure je le disais
effectivement on a 15% de Primo
festivals et festivaliers chaque année
et ce qui est intéressant c'est que la
première fois au festival peut se faire
à tous les âges de la vie et des études
de public nous montre que c'est un tiers
avant 30 ans un tiers entre 30 et 60 ans
et un tiers après 60 ans maintenant
effectivement c'est primo festivaliers
il faut aussi accompagner la typologie
je dirais sociologique de ces publics et
c'est pour ça que nous mettons en place
première fois pendant l'édition et puis
je tiens à dire aussi que le festival
toute l'année travaille sur le
territoire d'Avignon et à l'année c'est
7000 bénéficiaires dans 4000 jeunes que
nous accompagnons dans de nombreux
actions d'éducation je vous donnerai la
parole tout à l'heure sur l'impact
régional pardon nous interrompre mais le
temps le temps file et je voudrais
entendre Sylvie Robert sur ce fond
festival et sur la on va dire la
ventilation est-ce que cet argent
devrait être plus équitablement
distribué d'après vous ou est-ce que
c'est je reprends un peu ce que vous
disiez finalement
l'État qui promeut une culture élitiste
je
schématise volontairement on va refaire
l'histoire des politiques culturelles
dans ce pays depuis depuis
l'histoire moi je voudrais l'histoire
d'Avignon
l'histoire aussi d'Aix il y a une part
d'histoire dans cette après on est
aujourd'hui au 21e siècle on se dit que
il y a des enjeux qui sont des enjeux et
politiques forts ou la culture doit
je dirais jouer un rôle très important
quand Pierre dit ce festival en tout cas
le projet de Thiago Rodriguez et de
faire en sorte que le Festival d'Avignon
ne soit pas seulement réservé à ce qui
viennent passer trois jours quatre jours
pour voir des spectacles mais doit aussi
s'adresser aux habitants d'Avignon et
aux habitants du département de Vaucluse
c'est un sacré défi mais
bien sûr c'est-à-dire qu'à un moment
donné il y a des leviers
impossible à faire faut quand même se
j'ai 40 ans qu'on dit la même chose
voilà non mais c'est pour ça que je
rapporte de la Cour des comptes il ne
fait que confirmer ce que tous les
rapports disent depuis 30 ans je pense
du théâtre je vois pas pourquoi des
leviers à mettre en place qui sont qui
doivent être puissants d'anticiper en
amont de travailler avec les les ça
c'est un travail qu'on que les festivals
aussi doivent mener comme les structures
historique mais là on parle d'un fond
festival qui était plus sorte de fond
d'urgence après une situation post covid
donc là est-ce que cet argent là il
aurait pas fallu au contraire plus le je
voudrais dire c'est que je ne connais
pas la ventilation de ces 10 millions
d'euros je ne sais pas comment à ce jour
ils ont été ventilés sur quels critères
qui en a bénéficié ce qu'ils ont été
dispatchés dans les draps donc je ne
sais pas du tout
directionnale il y a une opacité totale
sur les festivals
pour préparer la loi de finance de mes
24 voir comment cet argent a été ventilé
ce qui serait extrêmement périlleux
c'est que des festivals et bénéficié
d'une part de ces 10 millions quelques
milliers d'euros et que en 2024 ce soit
terminé si on commence à structurer un
projet il faut un moment le structurer
dans le temps et le col du temps c'est
ça c'est que c'est pas des one shot tout
le temps
que l'État à autre chose à faire que de
financer énormément les festivals qui
sont pour moi moi je vais pouvoir font
la régionalisation et je pense que c'est
en local qu'on doit être trouvé l'argent
pour les choses qui ont lieu en local et
ça peut dur là-dessus et mais je trouve
normal que
ça veut dire c'est
et directeur du Centre d'Études
Politiques et social de l'Université de
Montpellier c'était tabou parce que on
estimait que disons que la culture se
justifiait en soi
et que une action culturelle n'avait pas
à se justifier de retomber économiques
d'externalité qui sortait du domaine
strict de la culture c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'art pour l'art ou la culture
pour la culture ce temps est-il fini
Mathias alors je parle sous le contrôle
de Michel Guerin mais on dit souvent
qu'on invoque les chiffres lorsqu'un
secteur est attaqué ou qu'il va mal
alors les premiers à cette emparés du
sujet sont donc bien les élus face à la
montée de questionnements sur le niveau
d'aide à apporter par les collectivités
alors dans leur sillage ce sont des
responsables de festivals eux-mêmes qui
ont commencé à dégainer étude d'impact
et autres pour justifier leur
subventions dans un contexte post covid
et d'inflation exemple en 2019 un
collectif de festival de la région Sud a
réalisé une étude sur les retombées
économiques pour les acteurs locaux avec
l'organisation de huit festivals sur
leur territoire résultat 153 euros
dépensés en moyenne par les festivaliers
dans les commerces locaux
62,5 millions d'euros qui sont donc
dépensés dans le cadre du festival si on
ajoute à cela les dépenses faites par
les organisateurs auprès de leurs
fournisseurs et salariés sur le
territoire l'addition grimpe après de 74
millions d'euros avec une enveloppe de
subventions à l'origine d'environ 19
millions d'euros alors on parle de de
rentabilité belle rentabilité pourtant
les acteurs culturels sont parfois
frileux à l'idée de jouer cette carte
pour y montrer patte blanche d'accord
mais de voir prouver sa rentabilité pour
obtenir des aides pourraient être un
risque pour le monde de la culture
encore selon Emmanuel Negri
d'un côté il est intéressant de montrer
que la culture ça peut rapporter plus
que ça ne coûte sur un territoire mais
en même temps il ne faut pas chercher à
s'aligner sur l'ensemble des offres
événementsiales au lieu de quoi les
festivals risquent de se faire
concurrencer par d'autres événements de
caractères sportifs ou des animations
commerciales qui pourront toujours
prouver que le rapporte davantage que
les festivals une sorte d'exception
culturelle française des festivals si
chers à notre pays qu'il ne faudrait pas
perdre merci beaucoup Mathias Michel
Guérin on s'est vraiment clairement
appuyé sur un article que vous aviez
écrit dans le monde pour pour faire
cette cette chronique vous disiez étude
d'impact c'était un gros mot et ça l'est
plus je me souviens quand Sarkozy était
prêt à la République et demandait à ce
que la culture soit le résultat un peu
rentable non même pas et rentabiliser
obligation d'un peu de résultats
tout le monde était tombé dessus et puis
petit à petit on a vu les choses changer
on avait etc et puis la première mine de
rien à en parler beaucoup c'était
Aurélie Filippetti quand il faut
excusez-moi de le dire mais c'était
quand même sous Hollande et c'est la
première fois que j'ai de la culture
baissée quand il l'avait jamais baissé
depuis 30 ans et elle est elle a
commencé à calculer des impacts sur le
fait par rapport au PNB des choses
regardez ce formidable
personne ne pouvait prouver personne
alors c'était vrai mais voilà et donc
j'en ai déduit en effet je me suis rendu
compte que plus on parlait de l'impact
économique et des retombées en général
plus c'est que ça allait mal alors
Pierre-Jean de Renaud vous les avez
évoqué ces études d'impact tout à
l'heure je veux bien que vous nous
expliquez comment vous arrivez à nous
dire un euro de subvention ça rapporte
je sais pas 10 8 15 euros à la région ou
à la ville comment vous arrivez à cette
époque qui fait l'étude quel genre de
nom on vous écoute l'étude déjà elle est
faite par des cabinets indépendants
auxquels on fait appel déjà parce que
c'est pas nous-mêmes de d'exécuter ces
mesures et par ailleurs effectivement ce
que je peux vous donner comme comme
chiffre c'est que le festivalier qui
vient à Avignon en moyenne dépense 20%
pour le prix CD et 80% pour ton
hébergement son voyage sa restauration
etc donc je pense que l'étude d'impact
elle est assez discrète il y a des
retombées directes assez importantes et
même majeur qui ont lieu à l'Union tout
à l'heure d'ailleurs il a été évoqué
deux sujets qui nous par ailleurs nous
préoccupe si on parle d'inflation c'est
justement le coût du logement le coût
des voyages et d'une façon générale et
sa structure un lien avec la transition
énergétique et écologique la question
des mobilités des publicités et vous
avez tout à l'heure parlé de Jason et
des trains pour amener le public c'est
quelque chose sur lequel nous
travaillons fortement Avignon y compris
en lien avec le Off pour faire de même
parce qu'aujourd'hui quand vous sortez
d'un spectacle de la cour d'honneur à
minuit vous ne pouvez pas rentrer même à
Arles qui est à 13 minutes de train donc
c'est un vrai sujet je crois pour la
suite et c'est à la fois économique et
écologique est-ce que les festivaliers
dépensent un peu moins cette année à
Avignon à cause de l'inflation justement
je n'ai pas ce retour là à ce stade et
encore une fois le festival a lieu ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que du côté
de l'hôtellerie il y avait des
réservations qui ont été anticipées qui
ont suivi le mouvement de d'une
ouverture de billetterie anticipée du
festival et quand j'ai croisé les
hôteliers à plusieurs reprises mais
plutôt en avant sur les réservations et
sur le nombre de nuitées et je viens de
lire une information qui dit qu'a priori
nous sommes complets à l'Union en termes
de d'hôtellerie jusqu'au 25 juillet donc
jusqu'à la date de fin du festival bon
bah voilà c'est un message intéressant
aussi Antoine Pecker sur ses études
d'impact voilà que comment je commence
en t-elle faites est-ce qu'elles sont
fiables c'est quoi votre avis là
complètement Michel c'est à dire que le
vrai problème c'est que ces études c'est
des agences qui vont faire une étude
pour faire plaisir à leurs clients et
derrière on a aujourd'hui un manque de
données c'est pour ça que Emmanuel
Macron à la fête de la musique a annoncé
qu'il va y avoir les opérateurs de
streaming qui vont participer à la taxe
sur le spectacle vivant qui va venir
financer le CNM le Centre national de la
musique et pourquoi je vous parle de ça
c'est que l'une des missions du Centre
national de la musique c'est d'être
notamment le lieu où on va pouvoir avoir
des données objectives sur le secteur
parce qu'on en manque terriblement en
culture aujourd'hui les études diwaï ou
d'autres agences qui font ça pour plaire
à leurs clients ça n'a aucune valeur
scientifique donc on a besoin de ces
données nous journalistes mais au-delà
tout secteur mais si on doit parfois des
choses justes mais on est tous d'accord
c'est hallucin à part le cinéma il faut
reconnaître qui est vraiment à l'unité
près vous savez en haut qui va au cinéma
à quel âge il a d'où il vient etc dans
le reste et notamment le spectacle
vivant c'est hallucinant le manque de
donner pour savoir où on va d'où on
vient qui vient commencer évolue c'est
impossible à savoir c'est incroyable de
même le savent pas et j'ai donc un
secteur qui connaît pas ses clients
c'est embêtant c'est les données
socio-économiques qui manquent depuis on
parlait de l'histoire et politique là
depuis 40 ans c'est vrai que ça manque
il faut documenter vraiment maintenant
c'est c'est ces sujets là et j'espère
que le CNM on verra le sur la taxe
streaming mais aura les moyens de le
faire il y a quelque chose bon sens on
peut enfin quand on parle d'Avignon ou
d'un autre festival enfin c'est évident
que vu le le les centaines de milliers
de de spectateurs d'hygiène ils mangent
ils dorment il consomme
et puis ce qui est intéressant c'est de
voir qu'aujourd'hui même pour le monde
culturel la conséquences économiques
d'un événement quel qu'il soit ça n'est
plus un tabou ça a été pendant d'année
il ne fallait pas dire que ça avait un
impact économique parce que c'était
justifié la culture n'ont pas par la
question de la relation à un spectacle à
l'art etc mais parce que finalement ça
rapportait maintenant je pense que voilà
les on a un peu dépassé on a un peu
dépassé ça pour autant vous allez voir
et moi je vous disais tout à l'heure les
JO l'année prochaine qui vont impacter
cette saison là et on commence à en
mesurer vraiment un certain nombre de on
mesure les difficultés qui restent il y
a des choses qui qui sont réglées mais
il y en a énormément qui qui reste à
venir moi je les mesuré au Festival
d'Avignon on en parlait avec les
organisateurs personnels techniques il y
en a plus
ça ça coût matériel et matériel ça va
être très difficile parce que finalement
alors forcement je voulais pas parler de
la sécurité parce qu'on est ce qui est
intéressant c'est de se dire que c'est
de se dire que oui on est dans un pays
où il y a plein de festivals été et on
va voir les JO pendant cette même
période et que à mon avis il aurait
fallu anticiper le fait que oui on a
besoin comme disait Michel Guérin en
local de ces événements mais aussi bien
sûr de cette événement exceptionnel que
sera les JO de l'année si beaucoup à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat
Antoine Pecker votre atlas de la culture
et publié aux éditions
Autrement merci encore de d'avoir
participé ici et depuis Avignon Pierre
Jean Reno le festival qui se tient donc
jusqu'au 25
juillet voilà c'est la fin de ce numéro
de sciences publiques je vous dis à
demain vous pouvez également retrouver
nos programmes mes tous les programmes
de la chaîne sur la plateforme public
sénat.fr et puis notez l'invité
politique de la matinale demain
Jean-Noël Barrault le minis délégué
chargé de la transition numérique et des
télécommunications belle soirée
[Musique]